We're asked to solve for x.
And we have this radical
equation.
1 is equal to the principal root
or the positive square
root of x divided
by 3 minus 2.
And the best way to solve these
is to just isolate the
radical and then square
both sides.
And then hopefully we'll
be able to solve for x.
This is a pretty straightforward
one.
But in general, once you solve
for your x, sometimes you get
more than one solution.
And then you always want to
substitute them back in to
make sure that they all work.
And in other videos, I've
actually explained why
sometimes you end up with a
solution that does not work.
But let's just do this.
It should be pretty
straightforward.
So the first thing to do if
we want to get rid of this
negative 2.
We could add 2 to both sides
of this equation.
Let's add 2 to both sides
The left-hand side becomes 1
plus 2 is 3 is equal to-- this
negative 2 and positive 2 cancel
out-- so we have the
square root of x over 3.
Then we could multiply both
sides of this equation by 3.
Let's multiply both
sides by 3.
And so we get 9 is equal to
the square root of x.
And then we can just square both
sides of this equation.
And if you square both sides of
this equation you get 81 is
equal to x.
Now, we only got one
solution here.
Let's just try it out.
Let's make sure that it works
for this equation.
So let's just evaluate the
right-hand side with x is
equal to 81 and make
sure it equals 1.
So if we take the square root of
81-- that's our x-- over 3.
This is our 81 right there.
Minus 2.
What is this?
Square root of 81.
We're taking the principal
root, the
positive square root.
So we're only going to think
about the positive square
root, which is 9.
9 over 3 minus 2.
9 over 3 is clearly, 3.
3 minus 2 is indeed
equal to 1.
So x equals 81 is indeed
the solution for
this radical equation.